en todos nuestros vídeos sobre
relatividad especial hemos hablado de
nuestro experimento mental donde yo me
hallo a la deriva en el espacio verdad y
el tiempo t igual a 0 una amiga que se
encuentra sobre sobre una nave espacial
que por cierto se mueve con dirección
positiva en el eje x verdad se mueve con
una velocidad v y de hecho dibujamos
diagramas de espacio-tiempo para ambos
verdad en blanco he dibujado digamos el
que corresponde al mío verdad y en azul
pintado el de ella y de hecho vimos que
el ángulo digamos que forman entre los
ejes temporales verdad es igual al
ángulo que se forma con los ejes
espaciales verdad de hecho tienen que
ser los mismos y estos ángulos dependen
de qué tan rápido viaja ella
algo que quizás has estado pensando en
esta serie de vídeos es digamos si yo la
percibo a ella viajando a una velocidad
ve en dirección positiva entonces desde
su punto de vista si ella digamos se ve
flotando en el espacio entonces al
tiempo t prima igual a cero porque pues
en ese momento es cuando coincidimos va
en el mismo sitio verdad también entre
prima igual a cero entonces ella me verá
moverme con velocidad menos ve es decir
en la dirección contraria verdad de
hecho estos ángulos tendrán que ser los
mismos que los que ya había calculado
anteriormente pero aquí incluso voy a
pintar la alfa al revés para que se
entienda que me estoy moviendo en
dirección contraria verdad es la
dirección que yo llevo ahora lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es usar esta
simetría verdad estas estas dos ideas
para que podamos deducir las expresiones
de las transformaciones de lawrence y
una buena forma de comenzar es con las
transformaciones galileanas muy bien
entonces vamos a poner
digamos como punto de partida la
transformación galiana donde x prima se
calcula como x menos b t donde ves la
velocidad relativa que lleva mi amiga
verdad y nosotros sabemos que con estas
transformaciones la velocidad de la luz
no sería absoluta dejamos de lado la
idea de que el espacio y el tiempo son
absolutos y podemos poner un factor de
escala aquí que voy a llamar gamma muy
bien que multiplica a esta expresión
verdad y en realidad esto mismo lo
podemos hacer pero con esta digamos
desde esta perspectiva verdad si yo
quisiera calcular la coordenada x en
función de las coordenadas de mi amiga
verdad de su marco de referencia pues
podemos hacer lo mismo tendremos un
factor de escala gamma que multiplica
x prima menos la velocidad que yo llevo
que sería menos de verdad por t prima
verdad y bueno así nosotros reescribimos
esto digamos de mejor forma esto será
igual a gamma que multiplica a x prima
más de t prima muy bien ahí tenemos
nuestra expresión para x de hecho de
hecho la voy a poner justo aquí abajo de
la que ya habíamos puesto para x prima
esto será gamma que multiplica a x prima
más b prima y lo tenemos entonces algo
interesante es preguntarnos quién tiene
que ser este factor de escala gamma muy
bien entonces para poder obtenerlo vamos
a hacer aquí algunos trucos algebraicos
para poder deducir quién es este factor
de escala entonces vamos a multiplicar a
x
con x prima muy bien si multiplicamos a
x con x prima podemos utilizar las
expresiones que tenemos del lado derecho
verdad y simplemente tendremos que usar
la propiedad distributiva para el
producto entonces primero vemos que
tenemos gamma por gamma y eso nos da
gama cuadrada que multiplica a lo
siguiente x x x prima verdad aquí sería
por equis prima y luego tendremos que
sumar x por bt prima entonces sumamos x
por de de prima ahora lo que podemos
hacer es multiplicar menos 20 x x prima
entonces tendremos menos bt que
multiplica a x prima y finalmente menos
de te va a multiplicar a bt prima verdad
entonces esto simplemente sería menos de
cuadrada verdad sería menos b cuadrada
de x de prima
de prima y ahora si podemos poner el
paréntesis verdad porque gama cuadrada
multiplicada a todo esto y ahora como
podemos usar toda esta locura toda esta
expresión para deducir gamma bueno pues
aquí vamos a retomar uno de los
postulados fundamentales de la
relatividad especial y es que la
velocidad de la luz es absoluta es decir
debe ser la misma en cualquier marco de
referencia y para pensarlo podemos
imaginarnos un evento que estuviera
conectado con el origen entonces digamos
que tenemos un rayo de luz
tenemos un rayo de luz que nos podríamos
podría digamos que ente y ente prima
igual a cero verdad en siendo una
linterna y entonces digamos que el fotón
choca con con algo justo en este en este
punto del espacio-tiempo verdad entonces
vamos a conectarlo con el origen
ahí lo tenemos y entonces pues esto
tendrá ciertas coordenadas esto tendrá
una coordenada x tendrá una coordenada
de verdad ahí lo tenemos pero aquí
tenemos que la línea amarilla que he
pintado es de 45 grados voy a que llevar
ya que este evento corresponde a un
fotón que se mueve a la velocidad de la
luz entonces si esta línea tiene un
ángulo de 45 grados quiere decir que su
coordenada x es igual a la coordenada
muy bien entonces esto incluso también
lo podríamos dibujar en este otro en
este otro diagrama verdad aquí pintamos
nuestra línea de 45 grados más o menos
es esta altura verdad y podemos ver que
también sus coordenadas podemos calcular
sus coordenadas x y 7 verdad aquí
tenemos la coordenada x se está moviendo
en esta dirección y podemos calcular la
coordenada 7 que estará como por hasta
cada verdad entonces ahí estarían sus
coordenadas x y ct verdad visto desde
este punto de vista verdad y también
podemos ver que x prima sería igual a 7
prima por ejemplo si lo vemos desde
desde este lado entonces trazamos líneas
paralelas a los ejes y vemos que en
efecto tienen como la misma
longitud justamente donde está cortando
verdad lo mismo podríamos ver aquí bueno
aquí es mucho más claro verdad aquí
estaría su coordenada act prima aquí
estaría coordenada equis prima entonces
podemos ver que en efecto x prima es 7
prima y eso es porque se mueve a la
velocidad de la luz muy bien entonces
aquí podemos usar toda esta información
verdad en realidad nosotros decimos si
gamma es va a ser la misma para para
cualesquiera de las coordenadas que
queramos entonces en particular podemos
usar toda esta información verdad que
que ya hemos obtenido podemos utilizar
estas coordenadas particulares x igual a
7 y x prima igual a 7 prima y podemos
usarlo para obtener el valor de gamma y
eso es exactamente lo que haré en el
siguiente vídeo aunque definitivamente
te recomiendo que trates de hacerlo por
tu propia cuenta antes de ver el próximo
vídeo